Hey, come see us for our fall tour dates.
We're gonna be in Houston,
Texas on September 4th
and then the dates after
that we're gonna be
in New Orleans, New Orleans.
I was kind of ambivalent how I wanted to--
Yeah you need to make a decision.
You gotta make a decision.
Birmingham, Alabama,
Jacksonville, Florida,
Tampa, Florida, Albuquerque, New Mexico,
Phoenix, Arizona, Sacramento, California,
and down in Valley Center, California.
Roundin' out at November 23rd.
Go to RhettAndLinkLive.com
to check out our stuff.
Now let's do a biscuit.
Welcome to Ear Biscuits, I'm Rhett.
And I'm Link.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we're asking the question do
we consider Los Angeles home?
What makes a house a home?
What makes a state or
a city or a new place
that you didn't always call home a home
and do we do that with
Los Angeles at this point?
Mm, and I do wanna just
go ahead and apologize.
This week I'm gonna be
the guy who apologizes
for being sick.
I don't even know if my
voice sounds different.
To me I sound like I'm
inside of like a barrel.
Well first of all let me
say that if this is just you
saying that you're gonna be apologizing
for all sorts of things over this episode,
then I'm all for that.
I'm only apologizing for if the sound--
Look at you.
Of me being sick.
See now you're saying
you're not gonna apologize
for anything else.
Don't shut it down.
If I do something
that's apology worthy, I will apologize.
Good.
But secondly, you do sound
like you're in a barrel.
I always, in my own ears,
I feel like listening
to myself now that I'm not
completely out of the barrel
because I'm not completely over the thing
that apparently I transferred to you.
I don't believe that you gave it to me.
Well how did it start?
Sore throat?
Yeah but as we discussed
on a previous Ear Biscuit,
all of my colds start with a sore throat.
What is it right now?
It's moved to just stuffiness--
Headache.
I would have a headache if I
hadn't taken Ibuprofen yet.
Okay, all right.
But what I'm saying is that--
It's not like I wanna take credit for--
But you haven't been contagious for,
you had not been contagious
for what I would consider
at least a week before
my symptoms showed up.
I don't know how colds work.
I've had this for three weeks, maybe--
But you had a residual sinus infection
which I don't think I can
catch a sinus infection.
I can catch the initial
viral cold situation.
Which maybe was on something.
Maybe you put it on something
and for some reason it lived
and then I ended up licking
something by accident.
I have been randomly licking
objects in the office.
Well I told Christy that
you weren't coming in,
you were just coming in
for this this afternoon,
not this morning because I
apparently gave you a cold
and she was like, "I'm not sick.
"You didn't give it to
me," and we sleep together.
And I didn't give it to my
wife and we sleep together.
And my kids who--
But most likely--
Especially my--
If you're gonna get something,
you're probably gonna get it from me
'cause the stuff we end up eating and--
We're trapped.
Yep, we're yelling
at each other right now.
I think we're trapped in the same room.
Imperceptible particles.
Yeah.
Being fired at your orifices right now
out of my orifices.
We're trapped in the same room more often.
My mouth.
Because obviously,
I share a bed and a bedroom with my wife
but I have a special
air purifier in there.
It's like constantly catching things.
We got a weird one that we won,
that our wives got from
Ellen, remember that?
Yeah.
We have a weird one from
Ellen in our office.
Christy and Jessie went
to a taping of Ellen
and it was one of those
days that she gave everyone
in the audience a weird air purifier.
And we've got it and it's always on
but I do not believe that it works
'cause it's never been,
filter's never been changed.
But Jessie always faces
away from you when sleeping
because there's a distance
between the two of you.
It's palpable.
No actually,
you know what, this is interesting
because you know this because
you and Christy shared a very,
very small single bed.
Double bed.
It was a double bed
but a double bed to me,
a person of my size, that's a
single bed, that's a twin bed.
If I get into a double bed with someone,
I am making full contact with them.
Also 'cause I sleep on
my side so I take up
a lot of lateral space.
I do not like to be, I'm
such a light sleeper,
I do not like to be touched while sleeping
'cause I will wake up.
And so, but Jessie is a deep sleeper
and she's also like a
super cuddle monster.
And so--
Cuddle monster.
So she, usually we wake
up and I'm on the edge
of my bed and she's in my spot.
She has moved me all the way to the side.
That's usually how we wake up but also,
she's like, and I think you've done this,
you've accidentally struck
your wife while sleeping
by moving around--
On a weekly basis,
I wake myself up realizing
that, in flailing my right arm,
I've either struck her
or almost struck her.
And the thing is is that I am probably,
if there was a spectrum
of accident avoidance,
like how much accident
avoidance do you have,
and I don't know if it's just something
about being really big and feeling like
I take up a lot of space.
I believe that I am on
the complete upper end,
almost off the spectrum
of accident avoidance.
I hate to accidentally
bump my head into things.
You sleep like you're mummified.
I don't step on people's feet.
A lot of tall people just step on people,
my wife will step on your
foot if you spend more
than four hours with her,
she will step on you.
That's just what she does,
I think it's 'cause she's
just little and short
and so she feels like
she can't do any harm
and so it transfers to the bedroom
and she's never really
clocked me in the face
but I have this phobia
of her elbowing me or
punching me in the nose.
And so subconsciously, I sleep on my side,
facing away from her.
You're like flinching.
But now that I've got this cold
and I have a deviated septum,
I'm giving you all kinds of information.
Take and do what you will with it.
My left nostril has a lot more air flow
than my right nostril, when I get sick,
my right nostril is almost useless.
But in order to lay on
me, you know when you lay
on one side and then
the drainage goes down
and one of the nostrils
opens up when you're sick?
Yeah.
That's facing her
'cause I sleep on the
right side of the bed
so now I am completely
in it and while I'm sick,
I'm sleeping on my right
side, completely exposed.
I've been thinking about
wearing a hockey mask
but I think that the hockey mask
would work against the air flow.
So I really don't know
what to do basically,
maybe a catcher's mask.
A catcher's mask lets a
lot of air flow through.
Yeah like a lacrosse helmet.
Or that.
Yeah something like that.
A football helmet would allow quite a bit
of breeze as well, like a kicker's helmet
that just has--
Just has the one.
Like the old school kickers
where it's just one.
They don't do that anymore.
If I was a kicker--
They got a full thing now.
If I was a kicker I'd have the one thing.
But kickers tackle now,
kicker's gotta tackle.
Gotta do it all, it's very competitive.
The world's a competitive
place now because,
I don't know.
Because of the internet.
Well I mean,
I had to resort to the neti pot.
I was like I'm going back to this thing.
And then--
Had you done it before?
Many years ago and then
there was the thing
where it's like oh don't use the neti pot
because you'll get a
brain-eating amoeba from the tap
and now when you buy one
it's got this big warning
on it that says use--
Distilled water.
I don't use distilled water.
You use tap?
Yeah because it's just a hassle.
I'm surprised, of all people
that you're using tap.
From one nostril, boy
and that feels weird.
I did it right before I came so
if I start going cross-eyed
then you know I got the amoeba.
Just be ready for it.
So I do have distilled water and I had--
Did something come out when you did it?
Yeah just a little snot,
but not a lot of stuff.
I love it.
I mean I had the
full-blown sinus infection.
I had colors coming out of my nose that,
I don't know, you could
paint a mural with it.
You got brown stuff coming out?
I mean there was bright red action.
Oh well that's blood.
Huh, that's blood, yeah, I was bleedin',
and then there was--
Hmm, I don't wanna talk
about this anymore.
Sometimes I put more spinach
in my breakfast smoothie
and it goes a little greener
and it's typically brown.
You need to see a doctor.
I don't think spinach,
I don't think chloroform
or whatever it is that makes, chlorophyll.
A little green action.
Makes its way into your snot
but I use the tap water
because those instances
of the people getting the
brain-eating amoeba is like,
it's so unlikely.
I bought a jug of distilled water.
And you know what, you should use it.
It is the wisest thing to do.
You can have the rest
of my jug, homie.
It also depends on your water supply.
We have the same water supply.
No no I don't think that,
I think that most of those instances,
I don't think any of them have
been in Southern California.
Also I have a filtration system
built into my house and--
Oh yeah listen to him.
And I have a UV light--
Oh listen to him.
I have a UV bulb, this is
the previous homeowner,
they installed all this
and I just maintenance it.
You got a central vacuum?
Yes, but we took that out.
You don't need that.
It was very old and non-functioning.
The guy, the family who
had this house before,
they were all about the central vac,
the UV treatment.
Yeah well it gets dated.
But listen, about that neti pot,
if you've never used one, let me tell ya,
you throw that thing on one nostril
and then you start leaning
to the side and first of all,
if you try to follow the
instructions on the back
of the thing it says weird
stuff like rotate your chin
but don't move your chin
out beyond the neti pot,
it doesn't make sense.
It's intuitive.
Just do it until it feels right.
Do it until it feels right
but if it feels wrong,
it could feel very wrong and
even when it feels right,
it feels wrong because
you're filling up that--
Until you get what you like--
My recommendation is to
watch a YouTube video,
but what's the worst that can happen
beside the brain-eating amoeba?
The first time you do it--
You could get water
going down your throat.
You feel like you might
be drowning yourself
the first time you do
it but then after that,
once you adjust and get the angles right,
'cause I made my, I made Locke do it.
Shepherd wouldn't do it.
Made him do it.
You just grabbed him
by a head full of hair
and shoved the neti pot in his nostril.
Tilted his head.
I was like dude,
you gotta get where you
can be in control of this.
Own it.
It's weird.
It's a weird feeling.
It's not that the feeling goes away,
it's just that you learn to expect it
but the first time you do it
and it had been many years
so it was very fresh to me, it was like,
I felt like I was fillin'
up my whole brain cavity
with salt water 'cause you mix
in that salt water solution.
Yeah.
And nothing's coming out
the other side so I'm like ooh,
and it's just half the
pot's going up my nose,
nothing coming out and I'm
like where is this going?
You're blocked.
Is it gonna come
up my ear?
You're blocked.
And I started hearing a
weird thing in my ear.
It started to burn a little bit,
but it felt like--
It's all connected.
Felt like my eyes were gonna float out.
And it's just, yeah, you feel
like you're drowning yourself
via one nostril.
That's weird,
'cause all that happens to
me when I'm super stuffed,
I can feel it trying to
go into the other side,
and then just going down
the back of my throat
and coming up my mouth.
Ugh.
So it's like pushing up
against all the stuff that's in there
but it can't get through.
But if a glop comes out, that
feels, that's satisfying.
That's what you want.
I think I became dependent
on it last time I got sick.
There are people who--
I was doing it morning,
middle of the day and night.
They got a new one that's powered,
have you seen the
commercial for the one that,
you don't even bend sideways.
You just put it on your
face and it powers the water
in one side and just out the other side.
Not necessary.
It literally takes it out and then puts it
into like a reservoir so
it's like putting on a mask.
So what, you can drink it later?
You could save it and
you could see the blood.
You can see all the nasty things
and know exactly what
happened instead of having
to look in the sink.
Oh gosh, it's a weird feeling.
Why we are talking about--
Getting your whole head
filled up with saline solution.
Anyway.
I feel like I've still
gotta shake it out.
I hope I don't have, I
hope what happened to you
doesn't happen to me.
I am doing--
I don't think
you could take it.
I am doing the neti pot ahead of time
so that I don't wait until
I get the sinus infection
to do the neti pot, however
some people say that
the neti pot actually
contributes to sinus infections
because it gets rid of the mucus
and the mucus is what's doing the job,
just don't mess with it,
don't try to treat it,
but it just makes me feel good, okay?
And livin' on the edge,
living right on the edge
of a brain-eating amoeba
makes me feel alive.
Every time I wake up
the next day after doing
the neti pot, I'm like
another day, I made it.
You sound like an anti-vaxxer.
Another day, I made it.
I know I'm not right about this.
I'm glad I made it another day.
Shout out--
So I could seem
right about it.
Shout out to all the
anti-vaxxers listening.
You're out there, we
know you're out there.
Way out there.
Jessica Biel's a big fan.
Okay so we're gonna answer some questions
that you asked us.
But first we're gonna let
you know that you can get
a number of grooming products.
Look at this.
We've got lip balms.
We each have one.
I'm gonna hold up both of ours.
Link's Peculiarly Perfect Peanut
Butter Peppermint Lip Balm
and Rhett's Wood and
Berries, wondrously wild.
You can get these in all types of packs.
Mythical.store, put 'em on
your lips and think about it.
You could also put my
beard oil on your beard
and think about me or Link.
You can put the Mythical
Pomade into your hair
which is what we do every day.
You can also spray what Link
has in his hands on your body.
Mythical Number Nine, this
is some good-smelling stuff.
I'm very proud of the
way that this smells.
You know what it should say on the back?
Smell of that.
It's--
We should call it
Smell of That.
And it has, we tried to
do a perfectly balanced
unisex scent.
I love it on a woman.
I love it on a man.
Yeah.
I love it on animal,
nah, I've never put it
on an animal.
No in fact,
it's never been put on animals.
Never tested on animals.
Not tested on animals.
Don't you, you make your wife wear that
when she wears perfume.
I don't make her wear it.
She likes it.
No no no no no
but what I'm saying is
that your wife doesn't wear
traditional perfumes because
it gives you a headache
but this is, I think it's
a traditional cologne
slash perfume but--
It doesn't give
me a headache.
But it doesn't
give you a headache.
So if you get headaches.
The majority of perfumes
and colognes give me a headache.
There you go.
This does not.
I don't know why it works but it doesn't
give Link headaches so maybe
it won't give you headaches.
Mythical.store, don't get headaches.
Let's start with a question that--
So we'll do the home question second.
Yeah we're gonna start with a question
that actually comes from my wife.
Oh really?
Yeah.
My wife has a rather
vibrant Twitter account.
Really?
@losfamgeles.
A little pun.
Okay, shout out.
Speaking of seeing Los Angeles as home,
she decided to call her, you
get it, Los Famgeles, Link?
You get it, you get it?
Yeah fam.
But she didn't respond to
us by asking a question.
This is just something she
tweeted that you're commandeering
for our conversation which
is fine but I don't want
to insinuate that she's
shamelessly responding
to our prompt.
She did ask me this
question as well though.
So technically I feel
fine about commandeering.
You may have seen awhile back,
it was already a couple weeks
when we were recording this
but Barbra Streisand, she
had a dog named Samantha
that was like a poodle,
kinda looks like Barbara but hairier.
Meaning Barbara your dog.
Yeah.
Kinda looks like, yeah,
and incidentally Barbara,
my dog is not named
after Barbra Streisand,
she's named after Barbara Mandrell.
But Barbra Streisand has cloned
her dog at least three times
because three of them are currently alive
and she posted this picture,
you may have seen it,
where she took the three
clone dogs to the grave site
of the original dog and
they, and the funny thing--
Did a family photo?
Did a family photo.
She put the three dogs
on top of the grave.
Okay.
And as you might guess,
they all look the same,
and then there's a picture
of the original dog, the--
Identical.
Yeah, the original dog has a picture,
like a color picture
of itself on the grave,
so you've got basically four
identical dogs in the picture.
Well which costs more, a full
color rendering gravestone
of a dog or a clone dog?
I think a clone dog
considering that she claims
to have paid $50,000
for it to have been done
or the news claims that
that's what it was.
And just a few years ago it
was $100,000 to get it done.
It's gettin' cheaper.
Price is coming down.
That's good.
And so--
Bye bye bye.
Jessie and I have seriously
discussed the question before
and I'm really surprised that as attached
as you are to Jade and how
perfect you think that she is,
why you haven't talked about
it, now I'm not gonna be--
Well her question is--
Happy Sunday, is cloning
your dog sweet or creepy?
She made a poll.
Oh she made a poll.
Over 1100 people responded
to my wife's poll.
The two options were, the sweetest,
with some dog and heart emojis.
When's the last time she
responded to your pole?
Ugh, well, not while I'm sick at least.
And then the other option
was that mess is creepy.
76% of people as you might
guess said that mess is creepy.
24% said the sweetest.
Well I mean once you set up the whole
Barbra Streisand does a
photoshoot at the graveyard
with three dogs dancing on
their forefather, foremother,
that obviously seems creepy.
Well yeah.
But so--
It's unnatural.
Let's detach from that,
let's forget that we know about that
and let's try to analyze
this question fresh.
Now, the 199th episode, so a couple back,
I mean we did, we had a
truncated conversation
about our dogs.
And what we would do if they died.
So thank you for your feedback,
being part of that
conversation, #EarBiscuits.
But we didn't talk about,
at least in my recollection,
we didn't talk about
cloning dogs as an option.
I think we may have talked
about it at some point
but not in that episode.
It gives me pause, I
mean I think about it.
Jade, I wonder if the personality
would be exactly the same.
I mean it's genetics plus environment,
the environment would be
exactly the same so I guess so.
I'm sure there's mutations that take place
anytime there's a clone but--
I might do it just to find out that,
just to see if it's--
Well let's just assume that
the price is reasonable.
I'm not gonna pay
$50,000 to have this done
but by the time Barbara's
in the market for cloning,
maybe it'll be 25, maybe it'll be 10.
Would you pay $10,000 to save Jade's life,
if there was a life-altering,
a lot of people pay thousands
of dollars if their dog gets in trouble.
We adopted our dog so we
didn't pay anything for 'em.
Actually they do still charge you.
Well they charge an adoption fee.
A donation.
A donation fee.
To keep stuff going.
But a couple hundred bucks, whatever.
But if you had to, Jade has
this life-threatening condition,
you have to get surgery.
I assume that you'd pay
thousands of dollars
for that surgery to be done.
I'd do that for Barbara.
I'm in a position financially
where I can afford
to do it and it's not a
irresponsible decision.
That makes the decision easier.
If you're all of a sudden choosing
between feeding your
children or saving your dog
at that point, okay,
it's a different story.
I mean another factor is if,
if we're talking about the surgery.
What are the chances of
success versus the quality
of life afterward, 'cause
we talked about before,
and how old is Jade at the time
versus her life expectancy--
Yeah of course, all
that take into account.
Ah man, I was likin' the overlap idea
which I've since pulled back from,
but now I'm going back in with overlapping
with an identical.
I would not pay 10 grand, that is steep.
Well it's 50 right now.
I wouldn't pay 10.
Okay, all right, let's take
finances off of the table.
Is it creepy or not?
It's free, you can do it for free.
Of course it's creepy
because cloning is creepy
and if we don't have a
slightly creeped out response
to cloning then we're probably
not in touch with ourselves.
It's weird, right, it's weird to be able
to clone something or someone.
It's not natural.
But the process
is not that unlike twins.
Genetically, which twins
are creepy on their own,
I do admit that.
Definitely.
But I think I would do it.
The main reason I wouldn't do it,
the main reason I would not clone Barbara
is because of the judgment
that I would receive
and I just would feel like
I'd have to defend myself
and I don't really have
a defense other than
I just really like Barbara.
Yeah, I don't think--
I don't know what
I'm gonna get next time I get a dog.
I think it should be
secret but if it got out,
it should be unjudged.
But there is also sort of the lottery of--
Why is Jade living so long?
Well she's--
She's 75.
She's amazing.
I've been telling you.
But I do like the idea,
first of all, okay--
Why is she a puppy again?
Maybe here's a reason not to clone the dog
from an ethical standpoint,
because dogs need
to be adopted, right, so by cloning a dog,
you're bringing another dog into the world
as opposed to adopting another dog,
so I could adopt another dog
that needs a home next time
just like we did with Barbara.
Yeah and I think--
So there's a reason to not do it.
There's something to
pair with that which is
it is a relationship.
I mean, our dogs are family members.
They're dog family members
but they are family members
so it's a relationship that then,
you just don't wanna have,
you don't wanna fabricate
just for your own convenience
a relationship with a clone.
It just seems like you're just trying
to perpetuate something and
deny something that is a part
of life which is death,
and an opportunity to
forge a new relationship
with all of its challenges and joys.
Yeah, what if the new dog's a?
Figuratively?
Then--
Yeah.
Yeah that's the risk.
So we got somebody working
on our house right now,
the contractor who, of
course, Barbara loves
because he is a person.
And the way he described
her the other day,
this may be weird to have a relationship
with your contractor in this way
but he was talking about Barbara
and he was like she is pure love.
She is pure love.
She's is pure love.
That's what Barbara is,
Barbara is just like, again--
You're not gonna get more pure love out
of another dog so that's, the risk is,
it's a guarantee that with your next dog,
you won't get that much love.
Right and so I mean I'm just like okay,
well this is such a good thing.
We got such a good thing going.
Am I willing to take people's--
It feels weird--
Sideways glances at me.
It's not like she's
gonna wear a doggy shirt
that says I'm a clone, not the original.
That would be funny though.
I mean what about cloning--
People?
Yeah let's clone our wives
if they pass untimely.
I mean I think that's why it's so weird,
it's like you'd never do that.
You'd never do that to a human.
It's unnatural.
There's other reasons why
we wouldn't clone our wives
because they would be a baby.
Yeah, you gotta, well
that's what I was trying
to tell you about--
It's like this is gonna
be awkward for quite some time.
That's why I was trying
to tell you about Twilight
that I didn't get to.
Was that that wolf guy, he
made a connection with the baby
and then waited for it to
grow old and then they became,
they hooked up.
That's creepy.
With the vampire's girl's baby.
Don't think of it in the
context of a relationship
because that's--
I'm telling you,
there's so much in that Twilight.
I could go back to it.
That's creepy.
But let's just say there's, okay,
there's a great mind,
like a person who does
incredible things, right.
I don't know, name someone who we consider
to be incredible that
does incredible things.
That Ryan's ToysReview.
Okay exactly, somebody who
has just impacted culture
for the better and we're
like well when Ryan
from Ryan's ToyReview dies.
What are we gonna do, we need him.
We could get, and when he's a baby,
it's like you don't have
to wait long for him
to do his thing again.
That's right, like within
three years basically.
Instant gratification almost
from a clone perspective.
The channel would be dark
for just a couple years.
Right.
For that time you could just do videos
that are just like retrospective,
like this is what you're
gonna get, don't forget.
Toddler toys, they
could start much earlier
than they actually did.
Start him as a baby.
Put him as just a newborn.
Newborn toys.
Are there channels where
parents just get their newborns
to review products?
Just throw a rattle in the
cage and see what happens?
Well there should be.
There should be.
I mean I think you can exploit your child
from a very early age if you want to.
Did I answer your question?
I don't think you have to
wait until they're five.
With our Ryan's ToyReview
thought experiment,
did we reach a conclusion?
Well first of all, can
human cloning be done?
I don't think human cloning
can be done as effectively
and reliably, right, or is it
just unethical at this point?
But could they really do it
and they wouldn't be screwed up
in some weird way?
Where is the science
of cloning these days?
There was the experiment,
I think it was in China
a few months back where they
were doing genetic mutations
for medical purposes but
it wasn't creating a clone.
It was using CRISPR on people.
But then there were--
Oh yeah gene edited kids,
yeah.
Gene editing kids
and there wasn't--
That's happening.
There's side effects.
There's genetic side effects.
You try to get rid of this one thing,
but then other things pop up.
Well okay so what if they
could create a clone for you
that didn't have a head?
Of a dog?
No of yourself.
Okay.
And they were like okay, we're
growing this clone of you
that doesn't have a head
and we're gonna harvest
the organs as needed.
You need a heart, oh we
got your heart over here.
That's cool.
In this baby.
In this baby without a head,
you're gonna get a baby heart.
You have to wait for the
baby to get old enough.
The headless baby's gotta grow up,
gotta review some rattles.
I haven't really spent
a lot of time thinking
about the ethics of this
but it does sound like
a can of worms that we
probably don't wanna open.
We don't need more people,
we've got too many.
We don't need to clone the ones we have.
All worms are cloned, by the way.
That is true, isn't it?
Are they asexual?
They all look the same.
Worms are not asexual,
I'm sure some worms are.
Oh, I was messin' with you.
Let's ask this next question.
Jennifer Hadorn asks how do
you know when a new place
you move to finally gets
that feeling of home?
In quotes.
What are the types of
things you experience
that make it a home?
You both had to move
far from North Carolina
which you have many fond memories of
but do you still consider
it your one true home
or do you get the same
feelings about California now
as you did with North Carolina?
Just as a side note,
I find myself watching our
Mythical road trip videos.
From Fuquay to LA.
This is Rhett and Link's America.
And so it begins.
The Mythical road trip
with Rhett and Link.
I can't remember exactly,
I think in preparation
for VidCon and a potential
bit about being on YouTube
for over a decade
'cause that's how long
VidCon's been going on too.
10 years, it's the 10th year.
I ended up going on a rabbit
trail of our own videos
after looking at other people's,
but I watched our, if you don't know,
our Mythical road trips,
when we moved out to LA,
we had fan meetups at rest
stops all across America
and we documented the whole
thing and we made all types
of videos, some on the
Rhett and Link channel,
some on what ultimately became
the Good Mythical Morning channel,
it was just our second
vlog channel at the time.
But we captured conversations
about our expectations
of moving to LA and our hopes
and fears were kinda peppered
into the story of meeting Mythical Beasts
and seeing parts of the country,
having never driven across the country.
Mm-hmm.
It was a sweet time
in our friendship, Rhett.
I'm glad we documented that.
And some people commented,
I'm glad I found this,
it's edited really well.
We didn't edit it.
Chris McCaleb did.
Yeah shout out to him but anyway,
it brought back memories
of that moment when we're,
yeah, it was a big deal
to finally uproot both
of our families, throw
all of our possessions,
actually we threw all the
possessions that we needed
to move into furnished
apartments so we shared a U-Haul
and then we towed my minivan
and then you and I drove out
and our families flew out
once we got to Los Angeles.
But I mean, that was a huge milestone
and yeah, as we did discuss
in a number of those videos,
we just didn't know.
We were coming out to
make Commercial Kings
for IFC, not knowing if it would last more
than a season and it didn't.
Anyway, if you wanna watch those, you can.
They're still out there,
the Mythical road trip but--
I know that I was probably
more than all four
of the four of us, probably
more than anyone else,
I was of a mind that we're not going back.
I was like we're going out there,
I don't care how this goes, we're staying.
You know what I'm saying, my mentality was
we're gonna go out there and even
if Commercial Kings doesn't
work, we're gonna do something.
We need to make it happen out there.
I was just kinda committed
to it and I think Jessie was
in a different way
committed to that happening,
not a this is where your
career is gonna take off,
but more I'm just ready for something new,
ready for a change.
She had grown up, we lived in the house
that was across the street from the house
that she came home from the hospital in.
Really?
Her parents' house was
across the street from our house
and she went from living with her parents
to being in college for
just a couple of years
until we got married and
we were in Chapel Hill
but then quickly got back down to Fuquay
so I think that she was
just ready for a change,
that's her personality so, but--
I think there was a bit more trepidation
on the Neal side associated
with the unknowns
of uprooting our entire family,
moving 'em out there.
Lando was in a crib.
Yeah Shepherd was two,
I was talking to him
about this the other day, I
was like you don't really,
your whole life has been in California.
Yeah Lando doesn't--
And even more so with
Lando who was a year.
He remembers, maybe nothing.
I don't think Lando remember anything
because Shepherd was two.
And he doesn't remember anything.
No.
Very, very sketchy stuff but--
So the risk was low with them.
But they would go back, we would go back.
We were out here for six months,
then we went back for a few weeks
before we came back out again.
To get the rest of our stuff.
I would say that where it stands now,
we moved in 2011, it's 2019,
so we just passed our eighth year,
so we're in our ninth year of being here.
And interestingly, when
you listen to this,
we'll be about to go back.
We're gonna go back to Buies
Creek to create something
that you'll find out about later.
But we'll spend some--
Oh snap.
We'll spend some time, it's
gonna be related to the book.
Bleak Creek, because Bleak Creek's based
on Buies Creek loosely.
More tightly in some ways than others
but we're gonna go back not
just to where we last lived
but to our home, where we grew up
and whenever I get to North Carolina,
especially when you go during the summer
and you're immediately
hit with this blanket
of damp, muggy air.
I don't think I'll ever lose the sensation
that I am home, that I'm
really, really, this is home.
Yeah.
This is where I grew up.
This is where I became a man.
The roots, man, you tap into the roots.
It's like gettin' back on a bicycle.
It just, it feels right.
And I don't think there'll ever be a time
where I'm driving around
Los Angeles or hiking
in one of these very deserty
landscapes around town
when you go into nature where I don't feel
a little bit like a visitor.
And I just don't think
I'll ever get over that
because if you moved around
a bunch of different places
growing up, which we didn't,
we were basically in Buies Creek
for our entire adolescence,
I don't think you can lose that,
so in my deepest core,
I definitely still consider
North Carolina home,
and I still feel like a visitor here
and I don't think that
I can overcome that,
but I have different feelings
just in a general way.
I can get into that after
we hear your perspective.
Well I agree and 100%
relate to tapping back
into my roots when I go back home,
like I just said, it is going back home.
This is where I'm from, this
is where my people still are.
Family, old friends, landmarks.
You leave the airport
and you drive back home,
I got grandparents still
living in the same place
that they've always been in.
I got Mom in the same county that
when I grew up, same place, you know,
so it's like you travel those same roads
and you access all of those memories
and nothing's gonna ever take that away
and nothing's ever gonna replace that,
but I do consider in
a different inflection
of the word home, maybe a
slightly different definition,
but I do have a feeling that
Los Angeles is my home now.
It is legitimately home for
me and I think the question is
how long did it take for
it to get to that point.
I think a lot of it has to do with
my kids absolutely
consider this place home.
This is the place where they've built
all of those memories and
Lincoln is hard-pressed
at 14 to have a ton of memories
back in North Carolina.
Lando has none and so it was
Lily who had to make more
of a transition but she
was still young enough
that it wasn't that big of a deal.
She had a best friend that
she's still in contact with,
she has a best North
Carolina friend Lizzie
who was in the Pimp My Stroller video.
Yeah, right, right.
She probably had the funniest voiceover.
Who's to say, there
were so many voiceovers.
But anyway, I think our
kids considering this home
goes a long way towards
me considering it home
'cause we're making our lives here
and every day is more memories
that you're putting your roots down.
But I also think it has to do
with settling in physically
to a house that, when we first moved out,
that first six months we
were living in Los Feliz,
which is super cool in
my opinion, neighborhood.
You got these hills where I
think Katy Perry lives up there
in the hills and then
you go down to the shops
and you got the, hey
let's go to Little Dom's.
Let's go to Little Dom's and
get us some Italian food.
But we stayed in this furnished apartment.
We knew nothing about where
we should be, it was just--
It was not decorated,
it was very cold the way it was decorated,
like super modern, gray, under-lit.
It just wasn't how I wanted things to be.
You like a bright--
Well I would go in the bathroom
and look in the mirror--
Antique, bright environment.
I couldn't see myself
in the freakin' mirror.
I had to buy a mirror with a...
I had to buy a vanity mirror,
like one of those makeup mirrors in order
to be able to see my
face in my own bathroom.
It just didn't, you know me,
I really like things to
be how I like 'em to be.
Oh really?
So that wasn't home.
I mean it was a furnished apartment.
Then we go back and get our
stuff and we come back out,
we moved into a house, we had a yard,
but I didn't really know
anybody in the neighborhood
and a couple of the neighbors that we met,
it was kinda like, I feel
like you don't like me.
There was a weird vibe in
the place where we were.
Yeah.
And we were, it was from
a financial standpoint,
things were tenuous for
a number of years there
as we were moving into
a painful amount of rent
at these places.
If you are in the greater Los Angeles area
with a family,
you better get it together very quickly.
Yeah.
Because you will be run
out of town just because it's so expensive
to live here, yeah.
There was definitely a year
or two there it was like
I don't know if this is sustainable.
The furnished apartment
that we rented cost
over three times my
mortgage back in Fuquay.
It cost over, it cost
seven times my mortgage.
I think you're just bad at math, dude.
No, I had bought my house much later
and my house back home
was pricier than yours.
Yeah, I got a really good deal on my house
but yeah, the rent for an
apartment that was smaller
than the house that I owned.
But it was furnished.
Seven times my mortgage.
Yeah.
That's painful.
We were fortunate enough to purchase homes
and I think psychologically,
you're really putting your
roots down when you're saying
I'm buying this place.
It's interesting--
So that's where
we're at now.
And I think that you,
with your personality,
getting everything the
way that you want it
is a big part of your
personality, less of mine,
so when I thought about this question,
I didn't think at all about--
Physical home.
Physical homes
and where we're at and being
and where we were before
and where we're at now.
It was much more just the vibe that I get
from the city, you know what I'm saying?
And I do remember a very specific point
and that actually was pretty early on.
It definitely wasn't while
we were in Los Feliz.
It was after that.
And where I'd flown back home,
and we still say flying home
to North Carolina, that's what we say.
We'll probably always say that regardless
of how long we're here.
But I remember arriving back at LAX which,
it's not the most, it's not
the most welcoming airport.
When you get to RDU, you're
like do people actually fly
out of here?
Yeah.
Is it shut down?
Because there's not
literally a crowd of people
that you have to work your way through
and a million people honking their horns
as soon as you get to where
you're gonna get picked up.
But anyway, every time you get to LAX,
regardless of what time of
say, regardless of what day
of the year.
It's a circus.
It's absolutely bonkers
how much traffic there is.
But I remember getting
back to LAX, walking out
and waiting for a ride
home and feeling like...
And I wasn't trying to
feel this, it just hit me,
I was like, I'm home.
This feels like home because--
But can you link it to something?
I feel like I am now
returning to basically,
the momentum has shifted.
There is a, what do you call
it when you get enough--
Tipping point.
Tipping point,
but you're like there's enough momentum,
what is that word that we're looking for?
Inertia.
Yeah, we're not saying the word,
I don't know why I can't
remember it at this point,
but basically critical mass.
There's enough critical
mass in Los Angeles now
and I think it does have
to do with familiarity
and comfort and so that does have to do
with the physical home or whatever,
but it just felt like the critical mass
of where I kinda considered
my home to be had moved,
had come with me on the
plane back to Los Angeles
and now I was stepping
into this environment
that I felt like I knew,
understood and could thrive in.
Do you know what I'm saying?
I know a couple of specific
factors at least for me
so try these on for size.
In general sense of community,
actually having friends,
people that if something goes wrong,
your impulse is to call
somebody who also lives
in Los Angeles to get help or advice
as opposed to calling someone
where you used to live.
I think that's a telltale sign.
Who do you call in need?
And then do you have friends?
Are you making connections?
Are your kids and partner
doing the same thing?
I think also it's like at
the moment you feel hungry
and you're sittin' on your couch
and places come to mind
that you can just get
in the car and drive to.
That are not Bojangles'?
Yeah.
Right.
You start thinking of, you know what,
I'm gonna go and get a so and so.
I'm gonna get a sub from this place.
I'm gonna get some Mediterranean
food from this place,
not the eight other places,
'cause I've tried 'em all.
I've got my favorites.
I know where I'm gonna
get the cheeseburger
and I'm gonna go to the pizza
place and when I go in there,
the guy's gonna know me by name.
I mean that's really home
when the pizza guy knows you.
I think another point is--
We went to the pizza place,
they were closing and
he said, and we're like,
"I'm sorry, you're closing."
And then he was like, "You
know what, place your order.
"I'll deliver it to your
house," and he knew,
he knows where our house is.
Yeah that's a good sign.
I'm home, baby,
when I can almost telepathically
order pizza, I'm home.
And trust me, I think that's probably
Christy's first measure of
home is do I know my pizza guy.
I think being able to navigate--
That probably took six years for her.
To being able to navigate the landscape
and not need--
GPS.
GPS, I think is, now,
if you live in any city,
you probably always have your GPS on
because you never know when
you're gonna run into--
Variables.
Traffic and accidents
and stuff like that but--
But you won't get lost if your phone dies.
Yeah 'cause LA is huge and I remember,
we used to come out here,
before we were doing Commercial
Kings we would come out here
'cause of course we did that
amazing hit show on the CW
in 2007 called Online Nation.
So good it got canceled
after four episodes.
But we would come out to work on that
and then to come out
and pitch other things
and we were trying to
make things happen here
and we would stay at the
Beverly Garland Hotel on Vine.
What is that on?
Vineland.
I just passed it the other
night where you're on Ventura
'cause we went to eat with
some people in Studio City.
We were on Ventura,
took a left on Vineland
and you go past that
little shopping center
that had the City Walk that
we would walk to the City Walk
down from the Beverly Garland.
Yeah.
Our world was--
That block.
That block and then if we were to drive,
we'd take the 101 through the mountains
down to somewhere in
Hollywood to do something,
to have a meeting, maybe go
all the way to Beverly Hills.
Yeah that's all we knew.
But that was it and that's
just a very small sliver
of Los Angeles and then
once you can kinda like,
oh I can draw, for me, I know this is,
Jessie couldn't do this
because I annoy her
to the point that I try to
understand the geography
in my mind.
Yeah.
But for me that was a big point.
'Cause in North Carolina, of course,
when we were in North Carolina,
at least up until the end,
there was no GPS.
You didn't use GPS to get anywhere.
You could get everywhere you needed to go
by just, you just knew the environment
and you kinda always knew where you were.
So when that happened
to me in Los Angeles,
it started to feel like home.
That was a big moment.
And Britton's been living
with us for half a year.
He's traveling a lot
with the opportunities
that he has for making music.
But our home is his home base but...
I don't think I'm going
out on a limb here to say
that he doesn't consider Los Angeles home.
After six months--
He's also living with you.
He's living in my closet.
Yeah in a very small area.
And we ask him, I'll ask him,
"So where'd you go today?"
And he's like, "I got
lunch at Jack in the Box."
And then the next day, I'm
like, "Where'd you go today?"
He's like, "I went back
to Jack in the Box."
I was like, "Britton, there's other places
"besides Jack in the Box.
"You gotta branch out."
So he started to do that
but he also pointed out,
there's a lot of different
menu items at Jack in the Box.
Yeah it's like seven restaurants in one.
They got egg rolls at the
frickin' Jack in the Box.
Yeah they got tacos.
It's crazy.
Jack is crazy, he can't be boxed in.
Jack is out of the box, man.
He is out of the box.
Jack out of the box.
Missed an opportunity there
for the name.
But it takes time
and you gotta meet people and you gotta,
you just can't eat at the Jack in the Box
if you're gonna make this house a home.
Yeah.
Egg rolls aren't bad there though.
I'm a fan but I'm the only
one in my family that's a fan.
I don't need to be eating
fast food on a regular basis
so it's fine.
All right let's move on.
So.
So we both feel like it's home.
Oh yeah.
And a lot of people ask,
do you ever think you're gonna
go back to North Carolina?
And there's no default, okay,
when we've done our time here
in Los Angeles, yes,
the default is that we're gonna
go back to North Carolina.
At this point there is no,
there's nothing like that
in play, it's like this is where we're at,
this is where our lives
have been established,
this is where like Link
said our kids' lives
have been established so I
don't see that happening.
But who knows what'll happen.
I love North Carolina.
I love living here.
And I don't, I miss things about it
but I don't miss living
there given the home
that we've made here.
Very happy.
I agree.
Russell Oehlert.
Pft, Oehlert.
What's your favorite song
to sing in the shower?
Hmm, favorite song to sing in the shower.
Listen, I don't sing in the shower
because I got too much on my mind.
Every single thing that
I'm doing perfectly
which I've spoken about at length
in an underperforming episode
of Good Mythical Morning.
If it hides, expose it.
If it flops, lift it.
Oh God.
I haven't thought about that.
Your routine is so detailed that
you don't have time for singing.
And listen, if you watch that episode--
What a missed opportunity.
Except the part about peeing on your feet,
stop snorting into the microphone.
Tay Zonday your nose away, dude.
I did a second ago but
then that one was just
out of nowhere, I just had to do it.
Just right into the microphone.
Yeah don't we have a filter for that?
That's what it sounded like.
Kiko, we got a filter--
I was talking, man.
For that right?
Tay Zonday that thing.
Okay turn away from the mic to sniff?
Britton saw Tay Zonday in Jack in the Box.
I'm lying, he did see him somewhere.
He came home and he told me, he was like,
you know that Chocolate Rain
guy, I was like yeah Tay.
He's still around, he's
still in LA, calling it home.
Yeah.
What was I saying before
you snorted all over myself?
Oh, except for the peeing on the feet part
which I was suggesting
that you do in the shower,
pretty much everything
else that I talked about
in that episode I legitimately do
and every time I take a shower,
there is a majority of my
brain power is directed
towards just...
What's the verb I'm looking for?
Doing, I'll just say doing my system.
I ain't got time to sit
there and just like--
Here's the thing though.
Pleasurably sing stuff.
That's the sad fact.
I think that we have
pin-pointed the weakness
in your system and I think
that this is a metaphor
or an allegory for many
different areas of life.
I don't wanna have a deep introspection.
I don't wanna--
No,
if you're too committed to the system.
Don't do this to me.
If you're too committed
to the system you can't
stop and enjoy other things
that could be happening.
You might be right
so I'm not gonna listen.
'Cause singing in the shower
which I definitely do,
because as everyone knows,
the acoustics, they make
you sound a lot better
than you actually sound.
I've done it since I was a kid.
Now I will say that I
have a window in my shower
and I look out at the,
I got a beautiful view
while I'm naked and washing,
I'm looking out the window
and I'm affirming myself and
I'm doing healthy things.
Affirming yourself?
Yeah remember?
You were there.
Yeah I didn't listen to
a lot of what you said.
I was just kinda the
prop for that episode.
That's fair.
That was late in the
episode, you had glazed over.
Here's the thing.
So you sing in the shower
now as well as throughout
your entire life.
And I wouldn't say it's a,
I would say it's like a 30% of the time.
That seems like a lot to
me for a grown-ass man.
What's the last thing
you sang in the shower?
Well the thing I love about
this question from Russell
is that I have a song that
I only sing in the shower
and I would not have been
able to tell you that
until somebody asked me.
I am shocked.
I would have bet, I would
have bet the amount,
the clone of Barbra Steisand
dog that you would not sing
in the shower.
Why would I not sing in the shower?
It just seems so vulnerable.
People can hear you, man.
I don't know.
You got lots of
misconceptions about me, man.
I think that--
You're perpetuating these misconceptions.
No I--
I'm a very vulnerable person.
No it's a specific--
On average.
I'm not saying that you're not vulnerable,
I'm saying it's a specific...
I don't know, it's like
we both have a level
of self-awareness that
I think would prevent,
I'm putting myself in this boat.
Yeah but I'm in a shower in my own home.
It's not being broadcast.
But like if--
To the neighborhood.
If Christy's walking in
and out of the bathroom,
I don't know, something,
on a psychological level,
I'd be like it's kinda ridiculous
that I'm singing in the shower.
Sometimes I will sing in the shower
and Jessie will join me
from outside of the shower
and we will sing songs together.
What is this, a Disney movie?
I'm just telling you,
that's the way it goes
down in the McLaughlin bathroom.
You know what, that's beautiful.
Jessie and I sing songs in the bathroom,
try to harmonize with each other.
It's not an uncommon
thing, it's not like half
of the time but it's not unusual for us
to start singing.
You know what, all right.
Let me, maybe this will
turn over a leaf for me
'cause I'm--
'Cause you seem like
the kind of person who would
want to sing in the shower
but you've gotten in your own way.
That's probably true.
You need to let go--
What is your song?
I don't even know if
I'm gonna say the right,
the name of the song
but it's by Dobie Gray.
What are you talking about?
It's not Give Me the Beat
Boys. ♪ Give me the beat boys ♪
No it's not--
♪ And free my soul ♪
I think it's called--
♪ I wanna get lost ♪
♪ In your rock and roll ♪
So it's no that one.
I have sung that song in the
shower but that's not it.
It's the Lovin' Arms song.
Sing it.
♪ If you could see me now ♪
♪ The one who said that he'd rather roam ♪
♪ The one who said he'd rather be alone ♪
♪ If you could only see me now ♪
♪ Oh I been too long in the wind ♪
♪ And too long in the rain ♪
♪ Takin' any comfort that I can ♪
♪ Lookin' back and longin' for ♪
♪ The freedom of my
chain, from my chains ♪
♪ And lyin' in your lovin' arms again ♪
I do not know--
You don't know the song?
I don't even know it.
You don't know that Dobie Gray song?
It's one of the best, man.
Ah.
It must--
It sounds so good
in the shower.
Better in the shower.
Well I've got a cold.
It didn't sound bad but I would hope
it sounds better in the shower.
♪ Lyin' in your lovin' arms again ♪
Huh, now--
That's my shower song.
In high school I would
sing at the top of my lungs
in the shower.
I've lost that part of myself.
I need to get it back.
I would sing Clint Black.
I sing Clint Black in the shower.
'Cause we were both going
through a Clint Black phase
and we'd sing a lot of Clint Black.
Lately I been singing
Diamond Rio in the shower
because I started
listening to Diamond Rio.
That's good.
I saw--
Pick a part.
I start walking your way
and you start walking mine.
I would sing the sad Clint Black songs.
♪ Maybe I took for granted ♪
♪ You'd be around ♪
♪ To pick me up on my way down ♪
See, I can't sing that low.
In the shower I could.
Yeah.
You know just killin' time in the shower.
♪ Just killin' time ♪
And I would get out of
the shower and my mom,
our house was so small.
You could be anywhere and
you'd hear me in the shower.
And my mom would say--
You sound good.
You sound so good.
So good in that shower.
You sound so good, I love it
when you sing in the shower.
And you've let go of that, man.
I've let go of it.
You left that back
in North Carolina, you gotta
bring it to California.
It makes it more home.
Maybe I need to move back.
No I think you can just
start singing in the shower.
♪ Give me the shower
boys and sing my soul ♪
I wanna do one more quick, very quick one.
I know you have a Rec in
Effect but Tam Brand asks,
what is the correct answer to what's up?
This made me laugh.
What's up?
Because I thought about
our college roommate Gregg.
'Cause typically you would say nothing.
Well I think normal responses to this are
nothing, nothing much,
what's up?
How 'bout you?
Or you could just say,
what's up, what's up?
You could say what's up back to somebody,
you could throw it right back at 'em.
All those would be--
I know what
you're gonna say.
But literally every time
and Gregg wasn't being funny
when he did, it was funny,
but he wasn't trying to be funny.
This is like right when we first started,
one of the first things
we noticed about Gregg
when we first met him.
Yeah yeah, you say what's up Gregg?
And Gregg says, "Good."
Good, he would say it like that.
What's up, Gregg?
Good.
And he had this,
it was like this carefree kinda bop to it,
like his head would bop and
his bottom lip would come up.
I mean he was good, man.
Support the upper lip
in kind of a smirk.
Good.
Yeah, 'cause he was under the impression
that that was--
He was under the influence of--
Not at that time.
Of joy, man.
He was under the impression that
this is the correct response to what's up.
And I don't know if we
ever talked about it.
I don't know 100% that he
didn't do it for effect
but we never discussed it.
There were a lot of things about Gregg
that we didn't wanna
pull back the curtain.
Just let him be Gregg.
Yeah it's like it's better to
just take it at face value.
Yeah.
Just like
whenever we'd talk about
studying and he'd say,
"Man, you know what you know.
"You don't learn anything."
Yeah.
That sounds like a sound
reasoning, foundation,
to not do my homework.
And I think, I've gotten--
And you fell for that a lot.
I've gotten many tweets
from people who say that
they are employing Gregg's philosophy.
You know what you know.
I sat down to study
and then I just remember what Gregg said.
I don't think that's great
advice if your goal is
to make good grades.
If your goal is just to
enjoy yourself while you're
in school and not really use the degree
that you're getting,
then that's good advice.
I'm not using my engineering
degree so it worked for me.
We did a RhettandLinKast
and we had Gregg call in
and we had a discussion with Gregg.
I don't know if that one's been posted
to the Mythical Society.
I don't believe it has but I
do remember that happening.
Hmm.
Okay that's all the questions, we--
Gregg with three Gs, love you man.
We took some time on those questions.
We'll get to more
questions next time we do
an episode like this.
♪ Rec baby rec baby one two three four ♪
♪ Rec baby rec baby one two ♪
Rec baby rec baby one.
I forgot I had to give a rec so I'm like--
Scrambling.
Racking my brain.
I was coming home, I was
gonna leave for work yesterday
and Christy sent me a text, she was like,
we got a teenager party
happening over here.
Lily had a bunch of her friends over.
And we're trying to be that house
where the friends come over and hang out
'cause we think that,
that way we can be in the mix, you know.
We can have our pulse on what's happening
and the friend group.
You can have your finger on the pulse.
I don't think you get to have the pulse.
Right, right.
Yeah we're not, Christy
tells me to keep my distance,
not to try to bop, get
in there and be cool Dad.
Just stay on the fringe.
Right.
Or be the guy who picks
up stuff that they need
and they wanted to roast
marshmallows on our fire pit.
I was like you know what, we've
been needing to get these.
And so I went to the
REI and I'm recommending
that you go to the REI and get,
they got these fancy skewers.
Oh wow.
I love it when someone
has thought about everything
associated with something
that you can just get a dumb metal version
to poke your eye out with.
It's fully retractable.
It's like a pointer,
it retracts in and out.
How much is this?
$13.
Apiece?
You get two of 'em.
Well how many did you buy for this group
of 20 kids that were at your house?
Well you know me, well--
You probably got four of 'em.
I got two packs which is four total.
And I told Lily, I was like--
So they're doing four
at a time and just sitting
around watching each other?
Well it's a party, man.
That's part of it, you watch.
You should have gotten
enough skewers for people
to pack into your fire pit
which I think 12 people
could be in the fire pit.
I told Lily--
It should have been 12.
I was like I think, when I
brought 'em home I was like,
I think you should, I
was like bragging about
look what I got, they're retractable,
they got the fork on the end and look,
you can hold the handle
and rotate your thumb
and it will twist the entire thing
for perfect marshmallow
roasting but with these four
that I've got, I would
recommend that you choose--
You didn't even get enough
for your own family.
Designated roast.
You didn't even get enough for the Neals.
They're expensive, man.
There's five of you.
$12.
This is a, what are you gonna do
when your family's roasting marshmallows?
There's gonna be one odd person out.
Everybody doesn't need to roast.
Someone's on graham cracker duty.
Somebody's on chocolate duty.
Somebody's an assembler and
some people are roasters.
I make everybody do all their s'mores.
Some people are better
roasters than others
and if you give everybody roasters,
eyes are gonna be poked out.
It's all part of it.
Marshmallows are gonna be burnt.
One person going to the
emergency room is part
of your first camping trip.
It's a rite of passage.
I found an awesome thing
and I ain't buying too many.
So you're recommending this but--
Yeah, four man.
I'll add a rec to the rec,
I think you should get
one per family member.
Then if I had to, there are two in a pack,
so I would have had one extra.
That's wasteful.
Give it to Jade.
Or it's back-up for when one breaks.
They sound like they've
got a lot of moving parts.
I'm the designated roaster.
Well then you only need one.
Two hands, two back-ups.
So is this an official REI brand thing
or you just can get it at REI?
You just get it at REI.
You can't get it at the grocery store
which is where I was gonna
go until Jenna told me
to go to Ralphs.
This is Jenna's rec.
Ralphs?
REI.
I was gonna go to Ralphs.
But you got--
But she recommended REI.
Did you get the marshmallows at Ralphs
or did you get marshmallows
at REI as well?
I didn't get marshmallows.
They already had 'em.
Oh.
You're welcome.
There you go.
Home is where the heart is
and your home in your ears is with us.
#EarBiscuits, let us know
what makes a home a home
to you, homie.
And we'll be right back
here again next week.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.